Vsauce Kevin here let's get into a
sleeve fight with style feet voice site
the poodle haircut was created to help
them retrieve wild game hunted near
water the bottom half was shaved to
improve buoyancy and let them move
freely in water while hair on the chest
and joints was left untouched to keep
those areas warm the shaved face and top
not kept hair out of the eyes and mouth
and later in the 18th century in France
the nobility began fashioning poodle
hair into extravagant styles to match
their own ornate styles dogs do in fact
sweat they just do it through their feet
when overheated dogs primarily cooled
down by panting which allows moisture on
the tongue to evaporate and their fur is
an insulator so most of a dog's sweat
glands are around its foot pads if they
leave wet paw prints on the floor after
playing it's probably sweat dogs know
what you're feeling because their brains
process emotion Laden sounds similar to
humans
research has shown they respond to how
we say something instead of what we say
barking may have evolved from human
training domesticated dogs have a
complex system of barks that humans can
differentiate while wild dogs barked
infrequently or not at all commonly
thought to have monochrome vision dogs
actually do see in color human eyes have
three cones that detect color while dogs
only have two leaving them with the
ability to distinguish between blue and
yellow but not green and red so a dog
rainbow looks like this
and we're left with sleeve fight during
the Tang Dynasty ancient China tiny
Pekinese dogs were bred to fit in the
sleeves of their masters silk robes they
were used not only for warmth but also
as a hidden last line of defense against
intruders and as always thanks for watch